da bist du ja ich mache ein bisschen weg
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
projekt und zwar geht der online
zusammen mit manfred hey ich bin mal
zusammen mit jonas von dem kanal mit
wir werden das jetzt erst mal jeden
zweiten tag bringen also zumindest ich
jonas was willst du eigentlich machen in
diesem projekt hier rumsitzen und
dummerweise nein ich habe auch vor so
eine art vielleicht eventuell best ofs
dann zu jonas hat jetzt gerade
hundertprozentig versichert dass er alle
zehn folgen ein best-of machen wird als
er wird versuchen ob er es kann
diese geht das tor nicht ab er wird
versuchen immer mal so ein best-of zu
machen er wird versuchen und sonst
zuerst kommen die folgen so weil sie
nicht alle zwei tage erstmal ich habe
nix brav nebenbei laufen muss gucken wie
das läuft und wie das hier auch ankommt
übrigens nie ihr könnt ja einfach mal
die kommentare schreiben ob ihr das gut
findet und nicht wenn wir das jetzt hier
so machen weil wir haben gedacht wir
machen ein buntes mischmasch kannst du
mal wagen nach jeder alt machen ja so
wirtschafts klären und leute erschießen
kurz 0 und alle sind gibt es witzige
jobs vom hochhaus stürzen machen in
deinem fitch mobil hier fahren ja mein
bild nur geringe beste leben master
nicht mal eine lackierung an leute ich
finde es richtig stark wie ich das fängt
mit kratzern weg mit kratzen hat na ja
also ich hab ein turbo drehen ich habe
einen achtzylinder
wir haben jetzt das geschafft da oben
schon kratzer drauf zu haben
da oben das weißt du oben drauf stand
das ist eine summe gewinnt
wahrscheinlich dass der dreckige
durchaus schwarzer diamant gedacht sie
erfolg machen einfach ein paar jobs was
ich im café hier ihr können und
schreiben entweder challenges machen der
d90 was wir machen sollen oder auch so
sachen wie zum beispiel cloud euch ein
flugzeug und fliegt einfach mal dahin
und so was alles so ein paar verrückte
sachen einfach die wir machen sollen
da sind wir auf euch angewiesen und die
beste es gibt es dann ab und zu mal bei
jonas auf dem kanal der auch in der
beschreibung steht
und sonst würden wir sagen dass wir
jetzt einfach mal nen job machen ich
weiß gar nicht wo sieht man in diesen
jobs ich will einfach am liebsten rennen
mache nicht einfach mal zu einem
radrennen da hinten ist glaube ich
dabei rückt also ich find online fahren
die alle richtig komisch
manche leute hier also ich glaube für
jobs müssen wir so oft start mäßig und
suchen jetzt das fahrrad dasteht fahrten
täglich stehen dann muss aussteigen so
ich dir jetzt da ich wünsche ich seh
schon cool aus ich finde mich schon ein
bisschen cool so was kosten
strandpromenade du musst das nicht
machen muss gleich ist glaube ich gar
nichts machen geht nur daraus ich muss
sich einladen oder kannst du irgendwie
einstellung ich mache einfach mal im
stadion spielen los gehts los sitzen
wird gestartet
okay leute das ist der erste job nun tut
jetzt wird uns jetzt wird sich
herausstellen wer hier der bessere
spieler natürlich auf jeden fall ja
sonst nirgendwo verdient so nutzfahrzeug
nehme ich dann was das für eine
beschleunigung hat
ich bin bereit ich setze sogar geld ich
selbst 580 befindet es kommt auf die
farbe rolle ich sehe aus - breit also
ich hoffe das klappt als mit der
belichtung weil ich habe keines aus dem
zweites oft box zu kaufen die von dazu
filme also ich hoffe das klappt so oder
gar keine feldkamp schreiben ihr könnt
uns so viele verbesserungen schreiben
die wir machen sollen weil das erst mal
dass ich so richtig professionell mal
mit der elgato auf nicht wird es auf
burg sunday ich habe mir ich hab mir
gedacht ich lampedusa du bist auch
minute jetzt kommt zu zwei ich glaube
schon
da bist du ja ich würde gerne wieder
ganz tot nicht da ich nicht mehr ganz
gut aber ich komme wieder oh mein gott
du bist einfach ein jahr vorne
ja ja ja ja sonst das unfair sich
einfach auf die baargemeinde gleiche
alter das ist liebt dann war es johannes
brennen
ja war schon mal weiter verwaltung der
mann das war krass ist ein bikes
bestellen ich weiß nicht ob einfach das
parcours in 1 genommen farbe oder ein
zweiter das auto sieht eigentlich vor
dass nach
ich bin ein motorrad fühle ich mich so
an zeit irgendwie ich hatte heute fast
unfall gebaut als nicht mitteilen
der fasten- und gebaut als ich beim arzt
sei also nicht beim arzt wird nimmt blut
abgenommen von eigentlich komme ich mega
was das was das gesagt nicht ob er sagt
ich hasse ich ahne was ja ich hatte das
auch nicht nachteilig wäre richtiger
bruder und die sagt sogar ich denke dass
man da rein sie sagte ja ich denke dass
man da rein und was steckt sie bereit
war
ich denke die nadel da rein und dass du
dir gar nicht weh
ich hab ja nicht so sicher von merck
doch nicht hingeguckt sich so ja wie
viel haben sie schon volk diesem jahr
zweieinhalb fläschchen jetzt ist wahr
ich ziehe jetzt wieder raus kann schon
hingucken ich gucke hin
man sieht so gerade wie sie diese nadel
daraus gemacht so klopp und man hätte
richtig diese bücher und ich spürte beim
letzten mal kurz zum kotzen alter war so
komisch und dann habe ich sogar einfach
nicht so cool tun dann so gedacht okay
ich gehe jetzt raus nein ich muss mich
nicht hinsetzen und sonst darf und dann
ich setz mich einfach ich gehe ich stehe
champion und ich fahre einfach zurück
auf die wiege und was so ganz kurz
bewusstlos sind also wieder sowie das
eine sekunden bewusstlos im fallen so
mann saß ich dann wieder so was ich
bleib doch noch mal ein bisschen sitzen
da hat sie mir aber an dem zwei bomben
gegeben und traubenzucker wollten noch
mehr profitieren
die dww was von dir auf jeden fall wieso
habe ich jetzt verloren
ohne witz nicht gewartet aber ich warte
jetzt kann auch bei dir wenn ich mal von
vorne sein sollte was machen wir denn
als nächstes was wir machen
doch die gunners gut erkannt alte du
bist schon du kassierst schon heftig
alter man kann hier warten also was du
für zurück
dieses wissen was du besitzt keine top
fahren wenn du vorne weg was willst du
eigentlich besser gta 5 oder gta san
andreas
also von der asse die story gespielt
getafe nicht gespielt
mein cousin gespielt weil ich damals
keine playstation hatte aber geht der 54
fand ich cool also gta 5 story fand ich
auch richtig geil sei es war auch gut
aber san andreas radioanbieter führen
welche strikes bekommen kann ich bin
aber kein netzwerk wie mache ich das
alter raus ich habe jetzt gar kein acht
das ist mit schießen
ja das ist hier ich habe wieder nur zwei
gar keine panzer um gekauft ja so
richtig so dass ich jetzt zu zwei cent
das ist ronny ich kann auch gleich mal
andere leute anders spielen
gegeneinander
ich glaube schon machte ich glaube du
musst dich auf bereit machen du blöder
ich muss noch aussuchen was meine
gewinnen zelebrierung mache keinen sinn
weil er nicht gewinnen ich habe eine
waffe ich sage nicht ich muss jetzt in
diese anstalt da rein fahren möchte ich
muss von der anstatt wegfahren und was
hast du ich sollte ich was musst du
machen mäßig sollten gut bei mir steht
einfach fahrt zu den docks weil mich die
taxis das beginne bei mir steht vor auch
zum dogs und dann schüttelt hände mit
einem feind schütteln valiant ich sollte
ich einfach nur treffen und auf gar
keinen fall wo du bist wo kommen doch
war stimmig gerade du bist aber nicht
immer der army base wo bist du bist du
noch vor dem dings weg bis 7
diese komme ich doch bei abgepackten ist
es ein paar probleme
ach so jonas unser skipper grad kurzweg
moldawier da wir uns die audi city
spuren nach schicken also die tonspur
habt ihr wahrscheinlich sogar gerade
gehört dass ich irgendwie mit uns
geredet habe ich realisiert dass ich
glaube in der tat fliegen muss die türen
sicher verspielt du bist nicht jede army
base oder nee ich fahre gerade diesen
weg dahin dass noch sechs kilometer
ach du sollst zur army bericht soll zu
den docks fahren nicht zu der army base
du musst ja zu mir fallen ja oder ja die
türen zugemacht das heißt ich glaube ich
so fliegen folge foult der stalker alb
tod ist auch halb tot
jonas kapiert das spiel ohne grund ein
flugzeug auf dem pad er eine 4 schick
war auf vier flugzeuge vor meiner nase
wies gucken wir erstmal vor weit weg
knapp kasse auch best ofs auf meinen
videos nehmen also da muss halt viel
gucken und ich glaube kontrast dazu
gucken ist sehr langweilig aber ich habe
gewonnen doch nicht du wirst das ist
jetzt nicht dein ernst wissen jetzt
einfach gestorben
ich hab die zweite in der reihe bildung
und ich gedacht dass wir noch eine
explodiert die suchthilfe an dieser
mission
da und herren gesehen ich bin zwei
kilometer motorrad gefahren und mit hut
hat verstanden dass er fliegen direkt
danach gestorben
was zusammen bist nicht so im guten
sachen was wir können
ich bin nicht so gut in gar nichts
fabrik im nirgendwo das ist ein zombie
wellen kg falsch ich lieb dich gerade an
reis vielleicht willst mich auch vorher
hinterlistig habe ich noch mal gewinnen
kann
vielleicht nehme ich auch bald einfach
die face kam mit meiner kamera auf
doppelten sogar noch besser als mit der
microsoft haben das ja also das ist dann
auf jeden fall geiler als du wir können
gleich nochmal der normalen welt rum von
uns einfach groß halters aus einfach
bitte warten
ja
dem gefällt der wende
ich bin aber eigentlich will ich muss
sagen passt schon
ich war einfach durch der zwischenzeit
in der zeit halte ich einfach meinen
tollen weil es die regel in die pace cam
der ist richtig leckere gewesen
an ihr ist der zweite aufgegessen kiwi
da seht ihr wieder was der jonas alles
kann die hessen krise überleben kann
überlebens ich habe den killer kerb
findet dass du hast du dich gesehen
übrigens ersten wilhelm und ich bin der
ich bin ist er wohl okay wir sind mal
nicht ging
ich glaube wir können nein das sind gibt
mir die andere waffe wir können uns
jetzt waffeln einsammeln und munition
rüstung schaltet die gegner aus ja es
gibt noch eine ganze haben wo ich weiß
gar nicht mehr wie steuern geht oder die
steuerung geht oder so ich sie da oben
so müssen
ist wirklich zu lösen sind das hab ich
nur so gesagt weil ich nicht wusste der
begriff gegner ein begriff ist wie
gesagt weil das du musst auch alle leute
töten
ja ich will erstmal york festival fall
gut wenn die erste welle schon vorbei
ist glaube ich auch gleich 1000 kills
und du ach dafür bieten eine sehr viele
realisiert ich habe unsere sonne pumpgun
alter nur ja ich hätte lieber seine die
schnell schusswaffe weil mit der hier
kann man so schlägt außer entfernung zu
schießen passte ganz gut
übrigens beschwert euch nicht wenn ihr
wenn irgend was meint ihr
heute kommt die durch ihn werde meint in
den kommentaren ihr seid noobs
akzeptieren wir
ist halt so hat der jonas sogar extra
für euch ich extra für euch vor zwei
jahren habe ich mir gedacht presse in
zwei jahren mit konkreter spielraum
kraft also ein vollidiot ich halt nicht
konkret hier psn dasteht kontrast 14
kills du dich für viele war es das jetzt
noch mehr will denkt man nicht die werft
ihr direkt der ba bu ich möchte nicht
werde ich natürlich etwas gutgemacht
da ist auch nicht kann er wechseln
wartet wechsel waffen mit airlines sogar
übrigens ich kann nicht mit den oder so
aufnehmen weil du sammelst gleiches geld
einfach die ganzen leichen gibt es nicht
weil die alle eine doofe xboxen und was
ist natürlich selbstverständlich besser
als der held box
euro das ist schon gegner alter keine
sorge ich hätte dich läuft erstmal gegen
charakters und von außen
danke gut
ja ich habe nur hinten in der schuld
also was schuss welcher geschlecht vorne
kommt vor allem ich glaube ich bin
gerade außerhalb des spielfelds
ja ich mache ein bisschen backup ist
sobald die faktische melle 2
die das spiel führen ganz klar dass der
waffen automatisch wechselt wenn die
eine leer ist oder macht es überhaupt
oder weil es irgendwie tasten fehler von
fehlt das war eine unfassbare plätze auf
jeden fall
es kommt nämlich mit taktiken ich gerne
drauf los
drauf los ich mache auch immer so coole
rollen nun will ich auch können kann ich
nicht ich weiß auch gar nicht viel warum
und aber er macht sie meinen also dass
doch ein gegenmittel hinkriegen stark
gemacht
du bist halt einfach der bar wo hier auf
einem ich brauche erstmal ärztliche
hilfe von einer typischen da nicht ach
nein ich sollte wieder aufs spiel
ich habe maschinengewehr was los ich bin
und die kommen schon wieder als ob ich
wieder da sind
rot-rote 50 so jetzt werde ich mal ein
bisschen taktik hervorgehen verkehrstod
nummer eins tot
diese kann ich denn die unami nicht
nehmen diese maschinengewehr verstehe
ich nicht
hast du schon 15 ich habe keins oder
nicht du kannst du auch noch in ein
waffen switchen mit verstehe ich einfach
oder ist einfach kacke ach der ist so
wie du denkst du dass es außerhalb des
spiels
da gehe ich auch mal in hey hallo bitte
ich jetzt fenster ach jetzt leitet er
darüber oh mensch ist eher witzig durch
richtige blut pfütze darf das überhaupt
hochleitner die so viel blut ist
irgendwie als ob ich bin richtig viele
trucks ihr bei mir
sie kam von vorne hinten seid ihr ja auf
einmal überall einfach wobei die ich
kann jetzt sehen hinter dem container
ist eine und behinderte wandern auch
überall von außen kommen jahre
ich muss jetzt ich laufe einfach direkt
in die arme nein
hast du eigentlich ohne beleuchtung
besser diese dann verkackt
ich habe die feste ja und gerade die
mission unseres lebens verpackt und du
deine vision ich trauer die mission
unseres lebens